hello there you are watching the press
preview first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive it's time to
see what's making the headlines with
royal photographer and biographer ian
lloyd and economist and former editor of
the evening standard emily sheffield
they'll be with us from now just for
this hour and they'll be back in the 11
o'clock also so let's see what's on some
of the front pages for you now
together yet apart the mirror pictures
william and kate and harry and megan all
attending the queen's jubilee service
but still keeping their distance
same lead story in the mail with a
similar headline so far apart
the times has words from the archbishop
of york as he pays tribute to an absent
queen at the saint paul service
the express also shows a shot of that
service with the headline we give thanks
the telegraph has similar sentiments
thank you for staying the course
but the guardian points out that with no
queen and the next generation of royals
gathering in her place it seems like we
are witnessing a new age for the
monarchy
the eye leads with the leadership
machinations within the conservative
party and a warning from boris johnson's
allies to the rest of the party that
without him at the helm they'll lose
the financial times reports a
multi-million pound lawsuit has been
filed against administrators of the
collapsed woodford stock market fund to
try to recoup money lost by investors
while the style reveals surprise
surprise that beer bellies are bad for
your love life
[Music]
and a reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and uh joining me tonight ian lloyd and
emily sheffield welcome to you both
let's start with the express their front
page and that headliner we give thanks
in reference to
the service today uh let's start with
emily
well i i think this this this cover is
wonderful because it really focuses on
what a celebratory day this was and
although the queen was not there i think
she would have been absolutely delighted
to watch
because
um the art of the artist of york gave a
wonderful speech which very much
referenced her love of racing and of
course she's she's also having to miss
the derby tomorrow which i'm sure will
be a huge sadness to her although she
doesn't have any horses of her own
racing but i think there were so many
wonderful elements in that speech which
was the reference to her staying the
course i mean she's 96
um and that she's still in the saddle
and also reference referencing that
there's still more to come and that of
course we hope that he's referencing
that she will appear again at these
jubilee celebrations but also that she's
still very much there and putting a
buoyant note on
what of course an awful lot of us are
thinking is is that she is 96 and and
the royal family are in a moment of
transition
yes the service uh a wonderful
representation of the 2000 strong
congregation um celebrating the queen
and as you say her her staying the
course in
yeah and the speech actually reminded me
of the one that she gave when charles
and camilla got married in 2005.
and they had a reception and everybody
was a little bit on edge about uh still
about camilla joining and the queen it
was the day of the grand national and
the queen made this speech and she said
about
charles and camilla they like the grand
national they've gone through the
difficult fences like the chair and
beaches brook and charles had brought
his camilla into the winner's enclosure
and he brought the house down and
camilla said at that moment she felt she
was part of the family so those speeches
uh horse related are
very much um attuned very much perfect i
think for the our equine loving monarch
you know
yes and the photo on the front of the
the daily telegraph that uh procession
with uh the prince of wales uh leading
the way there and that's really uh a
physical representation of the the next
stage of the monarchy emily
yes i mean
we are in a moment of of transition
because the fact is prince charles has
already taken over a number of her
duties in the last few weeks and he was
representing her today
and
the focus was very much on prince
charles and his son and the two wives
those four
working together which i can see as a as
a plan for the royal family is a good
one because you've got various
generations represented there which will
be a very broad appeal because the queen
of course is incredibly loved
and
the royal family is going to have to
work hard to keep that kind of loyalty
and faith
amongst the british and around the world
because the queen represents i mean so
much to so many people i'm i'm up in
yorkshire at the moment and i was at a
tea party this afternoon for 160 people
and there was a moment when everyone
started singing god save the queen um
and i and i and i i think no one
anywhere in this country
over this these celebrations
underestimates the huge power um that
she has held over this nation and that
she was such a been such a guiding force
i mean we saw that even recently during
covid um in that wonderful speech she
gave in 2020 after the first lockdown
when she said we will see each other
again we will be together again which
was such an amazing
sort of
note of of optimism and then also
that moment when she was mourning the
death of her husband and she was alone
in that church and and you really saw
the steadfastness of this monarch who
has been with us for 70 years
and anyway
sorry go ahead
i shouldn't say can i say it reminds me
of the monarchy of the 40s and the 50s
george vi called him
his queen and his two daughters we four
they were a solid unit and as the king's
health declined princess elizabeth and
prince philip stepped up so the queen
did trooping in 1951 because her father
was ill and it was a very small united
monarchy and i think that's what we've
got in what we will have in the future
with charles camilla kate and um and
william it's going to be not just
the next king and the one after but
you've got almost like a joint reign if
you like i think
uh and emily you mentioned that she's
much loved in in britain but also we
mustn't forget that she's also the head
of the the commonwealth and is also
their queen and we saw on on thursday
with the lighting of the the beacons
across the the commonwealth that she's
met much loved
all over the world
she is much loved all over the world i
mean of course we have had some moments
of um there have been a few problematic
moments recently the recent royal tour
um where the
you know not all the commonwealth are
are happy with the history of of the
royal family so i think that the royal
family going forward is going to have to
accept that the the commonwealth
commonwealth is not going to stay as
loyal as it has been but i i do think in
this particular three-day celebration
four-day celebration sorry that
everyone i don't think there's anyone
who doesn't have huge respect for the
queen herself and the way she has
conducted herself over these 70 years
um in you know there's no one i think
who can find a single word of criticism
against her and that's really quite
something
uh but emily speaks perhaps of the
commonwealth not being as uh um warmly
welcoming of the queen as perhaps in
times gone by but although countries
like barbados have removed her as head
of state they are still part of the
commonwealth and they're not we
shouldn't conflate
the two of
islands perhaps in the caribbean
elsewhere in the commonwealth becoming
independent or republics and not being
part
of the commonwealth
so it was addressed to me yes um
one thing that struck me being in london
is is i've done interviews with
tv and radio in brazil italy um
the far east as well as all the
commonwealth countries i mean the
interest in australia in particular and
canada is absolutely phenomenal over
this i mean there's still such great
interest in the queen and the royal
family and the ongoing dramas and so on
so it's it's um it's it's fascinating
that we still hold this kind of
international um appeal you know
let's have a look at uh the times and
back to the the archbishop the headline
there you're still
in the saddle that's the archbishop on
the the uh the queen there um and that
um
reference to her love of horses
back
back and running throughout it's it's
definitely a theme isn't it emily
uh it's absolutely a theme i i i quite
want to appeal to ian here because he's
got some one of wonderful anecdotes
um about the queen and the derby and her
many horses and
i i think it has been a passion uh we've
we've seen throughout her whole life i
mean she was only riding wasn't she six
months ago weren't there pictures of her
back in the saddle i mean it's kind you
know she's 96 kind of incredible really
yeah please don't think it's a great
passion for hers and i and i think when
you're when you're
turning up to as many duties as she has
done i suspect that passion for horses
as has what has probably kept her sane
during these last 70 years
do share your anecdotes
not that brilliant but i mean she's been
writing since she was four a grandfather
got her a shetland pony called peggy and
her dream she's one of all
four of the five classics the only one
she's not won is the derby she came a
very close second in coronation year
with oriole 1953 and she is desperate
not just to win it but to own the horse
that uh have bred the brother the horse
that wins the derby people have offered
to give her horses the arabs and so on
would love to give the queen the winner
of the derby she wants to breed it she's
got an encyclopedia knowledge i have
certainly encyclopedic knowledge of
horse breeding and that that that's her
big aim is to win that race and it's so
such a shame this year of all years she
can't be there and also have a runner
yes indeed emily quickly let's have a
look at the mirror their headline
together yet apart and they're talking
about harry and william
yes i mean that was with um
megan and harry turning up to a royal
event for the first time in two years
there was no way this was not going to
draw some attention
um i think harry and megan i suspect
were quite nervous about turning up
and i think that the cheers as they
entered into the church
should perhaps speak to the fact that
the sussexes do have their fans still in
this country even if certain elements of
the media would like to paint it that
they are widely loathed and
the way they are sat i think very much
reflects the fact that they have stepped
back from royal duties so they are
sitting in the absolute correct place
and the royal family and the queen in
particular as we know is a massive
stickler for a protocol
um
i don't know
whether the brothers are speaking i mean
it's lily but's first birthday tomorrow
we've heard rumors that the queen will
be attending and meeting her
granddaughter for the first time
um
and
i think most of the nation
we you know we're all from families and
i think most of us know that
a breakup in the middle of a family is
is not a pleasant thing and i think most
people would like to see harry and
wills
fix their relationship because they were
very close and they both lost a mother
so
i i think
i think i i would hope that over this
weekend it will be a huge opportunity
for
emily and ian for the moment thank you
we must leave it there for a minute the
break but coming up wallpapers including
this on the front of the eye their
headline johnson tells tories without me
you lose
stay with us for more
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview still with me royal photographer
and biographer ian lloyd and columnist
and former editor of the evening
standard emily sheffield welcome back to
both of you let's have a look at the eye
and this allegedly uh johnson has that
said to tories without me
you lose uh your thoughts on that emily
well
this is that he's looking at probably
and we don't know a
uh vote next week of no confidence
so we're waiting to see um on monday or
tuesday if um
graham brady gets 54 letters uh reaches
the threshold of 54 letters
which will trigger a no-confidence vote
in the prime minister
so
it's if
it's really hard to tell at the moment
because we've been here before you might
remember there's been a couple of crunch
points now where we've been told this
54-letter threshold
there's been a lot of action on the tory
mps whatsapps lots of people very angry
this is all in regards to the recent
sugray report where we did hear
extremely distressing details of vomit
up walls
people being rude to staff and i think
this has resonated with a lot of
voters across the country and what will
be interesting
i think is how many mps are hearing from
their constituents this weekend
and that's quite hard to tell actually
at the moment because
everyone's in the middle of celebrating
the queen are they going to be
complaining to their mp
it's also a very mixed group of mps so
as much as boris johnson and his allies
want to say this is the sort of ramonas
and um his old enemies coming at him
actually when you look at the broad
spectrum of the 48 who have already
voiced
their disapproval unhappiness in various
ways with boris johnson it's in fact an
incredibly mixed group
which is both going to be a positive and
a problem uh for boris johnson well ian
we saw uh royal fans outside saint
paul's booing the the prime minister
when he arrived at the platinum jubilee
service um but his supporters are
insisting that the conservatives
simply can't win without him are they
right i honestly
wonder to be honest from a royal angler
i honestly wonder what the queen thinks
of him because i mean you look at that
image of her at prince philip's funeral
isolated um not having her family around
her and
following the rules that's what she's
always done and that's her that was in
her training in her psyche she's put
duty first on all occasions and and um
her heart must sink when she thinks this
is the first minister of the country
that she's uh head of state you know
i mean it's just um it's it's staggering
her first prime minister was winston
churchill and uh you know you can't
imagine him doing anything like that you
know it's just
how she must feel that that um
the morals have eroded over the years
and we're we're in this kind of
situation i mean i think it's staggering
yeah mentioned winston churchill a hero
of boris johnson's actually um let's
have a look quickly at the financial
times and the the price of a pint uh set
to skyrocket to eight pounds emily
yes uh this is gonna be very distressing
uh for londoners uh especially as you've
got late opening times this weekend
tomorrow night and tonight i think
opening till 1am i'm i'm not entirely
sure of that of that fact but i believe
we do have some late opening times for
people to celebrate the jubilee and
people are going to be paying up to up
up to a maximum of over eight pounds uh
for a pie i would like to stress this is
a maximum there are still some places
i'm sure you can get a cheaper pint and
this isn't it to do two things two
things really ingredient costs are up by
10 which is a lot to do um with the war
in ukraine and also wage inflation is at
seven percent um so that is putting the
price up between 12 and 13
okay so i mean 80 pounds that's yes
i remember not long ago paying that for
a cocktail not a
but just to say across the country the
average price of a pint was three pounds
95 uh so just to give some balance there
ian and emily thank you so much for
joining us we'll see you in the next
hour